Jennifer Lawrence might be one of the
world's biggest stars but one of her
lesser-known films is currently
dominating Netflix there's an
overwhelming amount of content on
Netflix for any casual viewer but it's
always a bit of a surprise when an older
film like house at the end of the street
rises above the fray to become one of
the most watched titles on the streaming
service recently this 2012 psychological
horror thriller search to the top of
Netflix's charts and it's currently the
fourth most popular film on the streamer
in the United States despite the fact
that it's nearly a decade old whether
it's because of its big-name star or its
twisting turning story housed at the end
of the street - seeing a huge resurgence
in popularity here's why this forgotten
Jennifer Lawrence film is completely
owning Netflix right now and what
Lawrence has been up to since its
release directed by Mark tonderai house
at the end of the street tells the story
of a young mother named Sarah Cassidy
played by Elizabeth Shue and her
daughter Alisa played by Lawrence after
Sarah goes through a divorce she and
Alissa moved to a new neighborhood in an
upper-middle-class suburb though the
neighborhood seems idyllic there's a
dark story behind the house at the very
end of their new street what exactly
happened again I told you remember the
daughter Carrie Anne killed both
after the murder Carrie aunt disappeared
her brother Ryan still lives in the
house though the entire town hates him
against Sarah's advice Ryan and ELISA
end up starting a relationship before
too long ELISA realizes that Ryan is not
all he seems and that he's harboring a
dark secret in the basement of his house
as ELISA investigates further she finds
herself in mortal danger while Sarah
tries to do everything in her power to
save her unfortunately house at the end
of the street received largely negative
reviews from critics and it's rotten
tomatos critical consensus the film
earned a poultry 14% rating with critics
calling it poorly conceived clumsily
executed and almost completely bereft of
scares however critics did praised
Lawrence's performance indicating that
this young star had much bigger
opportunities ahead of her luckily it
wasn't long before her career completely
took off by the time house at the end of
the street was released Laurence had
already starred in 2010's Winter's Bone
for which he earned her first Academy
Award nomination she'd also starred in
the 2011 romantic comedy like crazy and
x-men first classes mystique a role she
would return to several times but her
biggest franchise was yet to come
lawrence starred as Katniss Everdeen in
the first of the Hunger Games trilogy in
2012 based on the first book and Susan
Collins young adult trilogy of the same
name The Hunger Games found Lawrence's
Katniss competing in a deadly game in
order to protect her sister and win
glory for her family ultimately
dismantling the entire system from
within after that success came quickly
for Lawrence that same year she appeared
in silver linings playbook alongside
Robert DeNiro Bradley Cooper and Jacki
Weaver for her performance as the young
widow Tiffany Maxwell Lawrence won the
Academy Award for Best Actress at the
2013 ceremony Lawrence went on to make
several more films with director David
O'Russell including American hustle and
joy in addition to appearing in
thought-provoking films like 2016
passengers and heart racing flicks like
2017 red sparrow the actress also
returned to both the x-men and Hunger
Games franchises for several sequels she
continued making prestige films as well
most notably the psychological horror
mother directed by her then boyfriend
Darren Aronofsky after such an intense
run Lawrence took a bit of a breather
although she has several projects on the
horizon
but even after a few years out of the
spotlight it would seem Lawrence is
still popular with Netflix viewers check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite Netflix movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]